salut les gars et j'ai attrapé la ville de riba
eh bien, va à cette adresse, laisse-moi tranquille
ma mariale
c'est une introduction rapide au jardin et au nom
culte
[Musique]
divers
nom
[Musique]
un bateau pour
mais j'en suis content
[Musique]
sans aucun doute
Sur
souviens-toi
[Musique]
Bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un trajet vers
le caniche se fait frapper
mais non
les informations orientées quartier
tu es
combinaison
[Musique]
sont des médiateurs d'alimentation
vérité
il reste une voie 2
les informations du quartier
Oui
[Musique]
aussi
ce dieu l'empêchera d'atteindre le but en
avec le
ici
[Musique]
pas grand chose en performance
flore extérieure
[Musique]
remarque ce que j'ai dit
hahaha
[Musique]
az
la tête
[Musique]
Oh